As SDA,
what are the doctrines and Bible texts
that we should know by heart?
That's a good question. When I was a
When I became an Adventist when I was a
little boy,
long ago,
we were given Bible verses to memorize.
We called them Adventist verses.
Revelation 14:6-12.
Revelation 12:17.
Revelation 22:12 and 14.
Uh did I say Revelation 12:17?
Revelation 18:1-5.
You had to know John 14:1-3.
Um Isaiah 8:20.
We were given several Bible verses that
we just had to know, plus some
quotations from Ellen White. Higher than
the highest human thought can reach is
God's ideal for his children. Godliness,
God-likeness is the goal to be reached.
Our ideas of education take too narrow
and too low a range. All these
quotations we had to learn.
And so those are some of the Bible
verses that were given to us, plus of
course Daniel 8:14. We had to know how
to explain the 2300. And I remember
going through it date by date, fact by
fact, practicing how to explain the
2300. By the way, that's what Jehovah's
Witnesses do.
They assemble in their churches and they
are taught. They are drilled how to
present what they believe.
We don't.
And so our people are just tossed over
because they cannot defend the basic
teachings of this church. By the way, I
have a question of my own.
What are the five foundational teachings
of this church? We call them the pillar
of the church. What are they?
The Sabbath?
They all start with S. The Sabbath, the
sanctuary,
second coming, state of the dead, spirit
of prophecy, state of the dead. Those
are the five.
We call them the pillars. Know how to
defend them if you are a Seventh-Day
Adventist. Study them. Let me say
something else. There is a very simple
book and I wanted to recommend it to my
good brother Joseph. It's called Bible
Readings for the Home.
It is laid out just like the Catholic
Catechism. Question, answer. The
Catholics know how to teach their
people. Question, answer, question,
answer. This book has the same style.
Question, answer. It is simple. You
study it like a textbook, you'll be able
to defend truth.
Find it, get it. Bible Readings for the
Home. All the subjects you want that we
believe
that the Bible teaches. It's not just we
believe, the Bible teaches them. All
right, next question.
Okay, these are the last three different
questions.
The first is, where will God put his
kingdom in the last day? Say that again.
Where will God put his kingdom in the
last day?
Where will God put his kingdom?
Where will God establish his kingdom?
Where will he establish his kingdom in
the last days? Now, when Jesus stood
before Pilate in John 18,
Jesus said, "My kingdom is not of this
world.
If my kingdom were of this world, then
would my servants fight that I should
not be delivered unto you, but now is my
kingdom not from hence." The kingdom of
God physically is not of this world.
Spiritually, it's in us.
Are you with me? Mhm. Listen to me
carefully. There was a time when the
kingdom of God was on the earth
in the nation of Israel.
When the last Israelite king was
destroyed, I think it was Zedekiah,
God no longer had a kingdom on the
earth.
So Jesus says, "The kingdom of God is
within you."
Christ says, "My kingdom is coming." He
told Pilate, "It's not of this earth."
When he comes, he will reestablish a
physical kingdom, but for now, the
kingdom of God dwells in us when the
principles of the kingdom are in our
hearts and lives.
The principles of the kingdom, which are
the 10 Commandments of God.
When God called the Israelites out of
Egypt, he only gave them the 10
Commandments. That's all he wanted.
Because of disobedience and weakness, he
gave them everything else.
A lot of other things. Listen to what
Ellen White writes.
Patriarchs and Prophets, page 364,
paragraph two. Listen very carefully. If
man had kept the law of God
as given to Adam after his fall,
preserved by Noah, and observed by
Abraham, there would have been no
necessity for the
the ordinance of circumcision. And if
the descendants of Abraham had kept the
covenant of which circumcision was a
sign, they would never have been seduced
into idolatry, neither would it have
been necessary for them to suffer a life
of bondage in Egypt. They would have
kept God's law in mind, and there would
have been no necessity for it to be
engraved on the tables of stone or
proclaimed from Mount Sinai. And if the
people had kept the 10 Commandments,
there would have been no need for the
other directions given to Moses. All God
wants from us really is the 10
Commandments in our lives as living
principles of love.
Oh.